I can't shake this feeling that we know
each other we do we do picture me I
guess maybe like 20 years younger but
like this Barsky
yeah what are you doing these days I'm a
journalist you're a great writer but
sometimes you're a little too much you
think I'm the perfect right portion it's
really nice to see you again okay you
boys didn't just call me a crash thanks
so much for being here as you can see
I'm I'm wearing the windbreaker that
Seth Rogen's character wears in the film
and it's bright it's colorful it's very
90s and I love it but I also feel like
it speaks to the theme of this movie in
terms of being unapologetically yourself
wear what you want to wear love who you
want to love write what you want to
write say what you want to say even if
you're running for president of the
United States of America
Jonathan it how accurate is that is that
I think that's very accurate yeah no I
mean that was you know we tried to make
the movie have these universal themes
that everyone no matter what side of the
political spectrum you fall on could get
behind so yeah being true to yourself
and remembering who you wanted to be
when you were younger that's that's like
a big thing and the windbreakers dope
like that's also I want to feel like you
had this windbreaker in your closet and
they were like yeah actually I rarely
come in with any strong opinions and the
only strong opinion I had was I see this
character wearing a lot of retro would I
worry I work windbreaker in words you
know we're doing this at South by
Southwest and I know Seth and Charlize
you've had some really great films that
that have played here and Charlize you
know did you ever think that you would
premiere a film and at the end of the
film you'd wind up on stage slow dancing
with boys
and while they serenaded you with I'll
make love to you is that like a bucket
list for you check it off hell yeah
dreams do come true yeah it just took
forty four years but listen it was worth
it and I don't know I might be carrying
his child it was a mixture of like him
holding me up and maybe making a baby I
would like to endorse you to be the next
president of the United States oh my god
they almost kind of wanted a Charlize
2020 shirt too I feel like a lot of
people are gonna walk out of this movie
I'll get you one
they're gonna see I mean what was that
like for you sort of playing a woman
that is running for presidency and we're
thinking and contemplating running for
presidency and and sort of who did you
look to to for inspiration for that and
what was that like I mean I feel like I
have this general sense that we're just
so behind when it comes to this the rest
of the world is beating us when it comes
to female politicians and power and it's
always so strange to me when people are
like who do you think it will happen do
you think I'm a good better happen where
we're in a lot of trouble you've been a
great Secretary of State which state
again all of them so I mean I felt like
outside of not wanting it to be based on
somebody or I think there was something
that we were trying to create that felt
like it hadn't happened before right so
I like that she was single that she was
in a powerful position and loved her job
and was good at her job it kind of lost
herself a little bit but ultimately
doesn't compromise any of her dreams in
order to to be with a guy who she really
loves and I I'm just really proud to be
a part of something like that I said I
you know you are the love interest of
who's that on your bucket list to play
Charlize Theron 'he's love interest in a
film yes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I actually have seven seven minutes in
heaven she's like one of my favorite
actors on earth are just getting to work
with people that you mire in the cup too
and and when you get to work with people
that were impactful on you before you
started acting it's like always like a
real thrill and truly surreal it was
Hannah I'm a big fan of she also
welcomed hosts and I said it's such a
versatile to sort of write the post
which is a political drama than this
political comedy or is this kind of
pairing written into the script you know
I'm curious to how Seth and Charlie sort
of got paired up we were paired up
honestly like it's a script we had been
developing for year eight years ago I
think we first got it and I remember
when I read it I mean it was much
different than and it's come a very long
way but it was mostly I was this like I
can only see Charlize Theron doing this
role basically and I could only imagine
being interested in making a version
where it was the two of us and and that
was mostly it I was just like as a fan
of hers I was like oh this was something
I would like to watch I just make movies
I want to see come back to you you know
we've seen sort of you know the behind
the scenes of politicians of who's sort
of on their team and what did you look
to for your characters was there
somebody that specific that you based it
on a million different people spoke to a
million people people people not in the
industry I researched everyone's role
because I couldn't understand my own and
I feel so scared we we did have someone
come to set who was the chief of staff
to Secretary of State under John Kerry's
term and he was really helpful John
Levine put me in touch with him so I
think I definitely was helped by his you
know advice and just like the energy and
the travel and all of that stuff but I
for me personally it was so easy to
understand why
I would want her to pursue this and not
get sidetracked by Fred filarsky there
was nothing yeah there was no sir I
didn't I didn't have to really talk to
anyone else about that I feel like it's
so interesting because these people it's
almost like the lives they live or
somebody else's and like what was the
most interesting thing you learned about
these that sort of part of politics from
playing this character oh man what a
bummer I don't think I learned anything
in yeah I mean III really I mean the
best part of it was actually when I got
the role and I got to talk to a bunch of
staffers and just learn about their jobs
and I also just read a lot of really
juicy stories which were interesting and
that's kind of the main thing that
someone in my position who gets to do
and then beyond that I just practiced
shadowing really powerful white people
and just like five feet behind people
okay I got to come over you you know I
in grid goes west to a certain extent it
was a kind of a dark comedy but I feel
like this is your first big comedy right
and you're amazing in it and you steal
scenes thank you you know what was it
like sort of you know transitioning from
like action movies and dramas to
something crazy like this well
everything every film that I've you know
trying to be in over this time is just a
show range you know just to show that
I'm here to stay so so when you have
this type of when you have this type of
environment you got these guys to work
with it was just fun you know Jonathan
and Seth they gave me you know the the
space to show my creative wings and they
let me get down and it's fun to have
people throw stuff at you see if you
could make it work on the fly so it was
a dope experience you know boys to men I
feel like I am a child of the 90s
it spoke to me having boys two men in
this movie and I'm just curious like
where did boys temed like where did they
come from
you know we started we wrote this kind
of party scene into the movie and we
started think about people who could
have impacted these guys when they were
younger and I have been a huge fan I
mean when when boys to men sang it's so
hard to say goodbye yesterday on set I
was basically weeping so like so like it
just they were like a natural fit and we
reached out to them and they were down
and they were so much fun and they were
down to play when when we got them onto
set and I got a rose last night Shirley
you